just off the tourist mecca of cancun
lies the Mesoamerican Barrier Reef's
system it stretches all the way south to
Honduras and is second in size only to
Australia's Great Barrier Reef but like
many reefs it faces threats from
pollution and warming ocean temperatures
and overfishing add to that the pressure
of hundreds of thousands of tourists
visiting the area's waters and the reefs
days could be numbered Jason de Kerry's
Taylor is trying to help in a novel way
through art the the sculptures are
actually designed to become artificial
reef units the cement structure that you
see behind me is actually a special type
of marine grade cement this engineered
to attract corals so corals adhere to it
they grow they make different formation
that in turn encourages fish and other
marine life his still ongoing project is
sinking some 400 of these sculptures in
nearly 30 feet of water and in just a
few months the statues already attract a
wide variety of life already this I
think over a thousand different fish
living on them there's lobsters there's
big schools of angelfish and there's a
big coating of algae which is one of the
first things to settle Taylor says the
colorful display indirectly helps the
natural reefs this particular area of
Mexico receives a colossal amount of
visitors every year
pink over 750,000 and that puts a lot of
pressure on the existing existing reefs
so part of this project is actually to
sort of discharge those people away from
the natural reefs and bring them to an
area of artificial reefs the layout is
important
basically Taylor envisions a big
neighborhood for fish and other
creatures
the configuration attracts fish so
there's huge schools of fish which
actually live above the sculptures and
then if there's any sort of predators or
any danger then they drop below and sort
of hide out in the feet area which is
kind of the idea you know around the
museum is attracting a growing number of
divers visitors need to go by boat to
reach this spot between Cancun and Isla
de mujeres the area's dive to our
providers are hoping to site both boost
business and helps maintain the health
of the reefs this is the perfect balance
where we're protecting the reef were
bringing tourists into the natural area
we're providing our to make it beautiful
and all together will help the museum
plans to continue adding sculptures as
funding is available the main
installation of 400 statues silent
evolution won't really ever be finished
since the marine life will keep adding
touches for centuries
[Music]
art and the beauty of the natural world
together may offer a means of helping
preserve marine life
[Music]